nous vous accueillons aujourd'hui guy a
lepage l'animateur de la célèbre
émission de la télévision québécoise
tout le monde en parle bon janvier à la
base on your comme apple et l'ont sa
merci alors regardez pas
on vous accueille aujourd'hui pour tout
autre chose pas pour tout le monde en
parle on vous accuse parce que vous êtes
l'auteur avec d'autres de la série
humoristique d'animation béatrice qui
est à sa troisième saison sur ici telle
est la télévision de radio canada ainsi
que sur tou.tv le service de vidéo à la
demande sur internet de radio-canada
aussi première question qui vient à
l'esprit est guère lepage
comment vous est venue l'idée de
transposer votre quotidien et vos
interactions avec votre fille de 4 ans
on y sert est ce que vous aviez un
bloc-notes et un crayon et que vous
suivez tout le temps pour faire sans
elle mais j'avais j'avais un compte
twitter et qu'elle faisait quand ma
fille est un mot que je trouvais amusant
jeunes apej lui qui vivait sur twitter
et je m'étais le hashtag bébé à tenir
les très rapidement c'est devenu
vraiment virale très populaire est un
catcheur dessinateur patrick godin
il est présentement de qualité celle de
voir qui que se connaître à thème il
m'envoyait quelques sketchs vous y
mettez en images ces petits boulots qui
t'a fonctionnaires principale route puis
maudit pense qu'on peut faire quelque
chose avec ce giga watts envoyé une
trentaine de grands thèmes ou
quarantaine de petits commentaires que
les sociétés on va voir il m'a envoyé
une quarantaine de dessins qui ont
trouvé ça drôle
puis on est allé voir la presse
l'éruption la presse qui nous aurait
parallèlement publié alors béatrice est
devenu le plus jeune homme oui je veux
que les caisses que son non autorisées
sur le livre eu exactement un prêt tél
et dès le lancement du livre
mais au delà de l'anecdotique des
interactions est-ce que vous avez
quelque chose à exprimer pour à travers
cette série tv
afin qu'ils soient formatées par l'école
et l'éducation des esprits libres il dit
tout ce qui leur passe par la tête des
fois c'est poétique donc faussé
complètement trash des fois t'es odieux
dont une fois c'est certainement
millions moi j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
une fille qui était une mitraillette
localement des répliques comme ça il en
sortir en france par semaine mais j'ai
eu la pudeur de publier ce jusqu'au jour
où il ya eu les attentats de charlie
hebdo
je vais t'expliquer pourquoi parce que
mon tour était ma fille probablement
comme tous les parents du monde entier
trouvent avec son charmant mais gagner
les attentes de charlie hebdo
moi je regardais le évidemment le
téléjournal puis les nouvelles hi-fi
autres bêtes en france aux états unis en
vedette pendant des années 10 heures en
oubliant tout est combiné quelques-uns
la mode tv sur la manche
elle m'a dit tu sais papa quand même pas
1 des fonds il faut pas tuer les gens
ont tous la feuille de l'autre côté et
on décide de l'onba c'est tout et vous
en avez la scotch et ouais je vous en
remercie d'être là je me suis dit ok
elle elle est dans les ligues majeures
niveau de la saisie d'ailleurs j'ai dit
oui et tu le fais en télé sont devenus
deux le maintenant la troisième étape et
en diffusion puis l'écriture des 4e et m
et comment est-ce que de béatrice
béatrice vie maintenant je pense qu'elle
doit avoir dans les dix ans 12 ans quand
ça comment est ce qu'elle vit un bébé
attriste le personnage mais ma fille est
l'un des pions 14 donc évidemment été un
autre niveau surtout pour les jeunes
pilotes et donc saviez liedtke le pimac
les garçons alors pour est une oeuvre de
jeunesse et regarde cela avec de la
tâche mais sans excès ou
ou vraiment confrontés à ça parce que
c'est quand il était jeune dites-moi
quand même béatrice après un succès
c'est il est dû à quoi ce succès alors
leur personnage à votre travail à vous
ce que vous avez vous puisque vous en
être l'auteur ben moi je dirais que tout
part de [ __ ] donc les personnages
très bien et très bien interprété
d'ailleurs il y attend pierre laiterie
formidable mais je pense que ce qui
trait singulier de cette émission c'est
la mise en image des défunts la réaliser
les dessins des godets l'organisation
des noubas ça marche bien il faut
s'inquiéter au sujet à faire que le 3d
là et qu'on a décidé que la signature
visuelle le particulière et elle livre
moi j'aime beaucoup beaucoup ce qui je
suis sûr que ça contribue au succès
l'unisson mais certainement
on a remarqué que pour la saison 3 où
vous avez vous avez donné un peu de
place à la diversité par exemple on voit
qu'il y a qu'à un moment de béatrice
tombe amoureuse d'un homme là une
amourette éphémère avec un trac elle est
aussi là sa grande amie madame julie
qu'il est une personne trans un brin
comment on est venu à ça et c'est dans
notre communauté où on habite
moi j'habite au centre-ville de montréal
alors qu'il ne votera dans une classe et
homogène je dirai tout les doutes ni
communautés sont représentés
probablement tous les gens de famille
aussi à la reynerie la dinde banane pas
illégal façon que mieux ils posent des
questions mais sont souvent champ en
jugement qu'on voit un enfant qui jugent
leur général parce qu attendu ses
parents jugés
oui alors pour elle béatrice de
rencontrer une personne étrange ce plan
qui est super gentil
elle c'est son ami qui lui pose des
questions d'enfants
pourquoi tu écris ton pénis qui est très
contente maintenant qu'est-ce que ça
fait mal
pis ce personnage yeux de la personne
transgenre était dans la deuxième saison
aussi si je la rencontre et avait avec
ma fille moi sur internet le papa y
faisait
excusez ma fille parce qu'elle pose les
questions personnelles qui la personne
plantes répondez vous savez c'est les
enfants qui nous jugent mois alors que
posent explique évidemment de son amour
wii fit évidemment son amour pour tallec
pour le gène tallec mais c'est normal
les femmes c'est un dojo de quelques
sujets d'ailleurs piqué la cuillère way
we kara scott stuber et où sa façon de
l'état lesquelles la rencontre au papier
joue avec ma vie ça me prenait à peine
d'amour parce qu'il savait que votre
tombe dans ce pays puis elles sont
premières donc béatrice peut aussi
participer à une genre
d'interculturalisme avec les nouveaux
arrivants ça peut participer aussi à
démystifier la la société québécoise
pour les nouveaux arrivants ça peut être
on peut le prendre
vous avez raison mais pour tous ceux qui
habitent là mondiale depuis mon dieu 40
les communautés culturelles sont
installés alors ça fait partie de notre
quotidien de tutoyer on vit avec eux
l'ont les rangs quand on les foulées car
on a ce sera pour les gens qui habitent
vraiment très très loin de montréal mais
pour nous c'est une réalité qui est
normalement bon tu vieux 29 ans et sa
classe était à sudbury aussi puis moi
c'est ça que je veux d'ailleurs je veux
obliger votre nez d'enfants sont élevées
à la diversité qui tu vois qu'on peut
être heureux en état modestement dissous
dénichez qu'on peut être heureux avec en
étant un enfant que des paroles c'est
pas lui qui sont ensemble qui sont du
même genre ou non tout ça se peut toutes
les possibilités oui tout à fait mais
oui tu agis les tours
regardez il ya deux bases la saison 3
vient de sortir mais parce que je
déplore un peu j'attendais ce qu'il y
ait au moins un mas ou une copie 19
victoires au pourquoi j'ai cherché j'ai
pas trouvé mais parce que premièrement
il a été négligent deuxième là je pense
que collectivement nous avons
collectivement vous de regarder ça alors
j'ai envie que quelqu'un ne regarde pas
au la cbi et béatrice saison 3 parce que
tout le monde a des manques
qu'est-ce qu'on est un peu la troupe sa
femme aussi la littérature et gély film
c'est de nous évader le projet de nous
rappeler à quel point on des profilés
cette année de merde que nous terminons
alors béatrice quatrième saison c'est
déjà annoncées escudé béatrice pour
avoir les béatrice la série pourra avoir
une vie en dehors du québec
vous avez déjà eu du succès avec un gars
une fille à ce que parce que béatrice
pourrait avoir le cheminement oui on
fait des dessins animés tels chemins de
fer le doublage il fonctionne lui on a
toutes les techniques offertes en euros
toutefois qu'il écoute pour les faire
soit montréal ou en partenariat avec
donc notre objectif diffuseur à
l'extérieur ben oui mes travaux oui la
réponse est oui mais tout comme un jeune
fille est pas pour ça que les privés et
et koné au départ que des hybrides parce
que les conséquences de la grippe c'est
tant mieux mais moi je me jugeais
préfectoral d'âge faire un tour du monde
oui exactement écoutez merci beaucoup
guy a lepage je rappelle que vous êtes
auteur vous êtes l'auteur de la série
humoristique d'animation béatrice sur
this i télé la télévision de radio
canada
et qui est aussi disponible sur tou.tv
le service web de vidéo à la demande de
radio canada
merci beaucoup